la ministre mes chers collègues nos
armées sont engagées dans des opérations
qui s'inscrivent dans la durée
elles doivent disposer de la meilleure
technologie vous souhaitez promouvoir
prioritairement les technologies
françaises et les coopérations
européennes
c'est une bonne chose la france compte
dans le domaine de la défense de grands
groupes mais aussi des pme voire des
start-up souvent plus vulnérables la
compétition fait rage entre les grandes
puissances
nous devons donc conserver nos
compétences pour l'avenir de nos
industries et celui de nos opérations
pourtant nous constatons avec inquiétude
l'intérêt que suscite à l'étranger
notamment aux états unis
quelques entreprises françaises de
technologies sensibles ces précieuses
pépites attire souvent les convoitises
et certaines sont déjà passés sous
pavillon étranger
d'autres seraient en passe de l'être ce
n'est pas une bonne nouvelle pour notre
souveraineté
s'agissant de photos nice l'un des
leaders mondiaux dans les
intensificateur de lumière en
particulier utilisé par nos forces
spéciales lorsque j'ai interrogé en
commission le dg a il s'était montré
rassurant
aujourd'hui le temps s'est écoulé et
j'entends qu'aucune solution
industrielle française ne semble se
dégager
quand des acheteurs non européens sont
déjà prêts il y a donc urgence à agir
dès lors madame la ministre
considérez-vous photonis comme
stratégique et êtes vous réellement
capable de préserver nos pépites
industriels du secteur de la défense
l'union européenne doit-elle nous y
aider